dans les buzz du jour aujourd'hui en
parle rentrée des classes et cantines
scolaires avec une mesure prise à
grenoble le menu par défaut qui est tout
le temps proposé c'est le menu
végétarien une mesure mise en place par
le maire écologiste de la ville eric
piolle triple enjeu les gaz à effet de
serre la santé et la condition animale
pour croire que l'apparition de ce
nouveau menu est loin de faire
l'unanimité au fonds canadien se
concentre la majorité des parents
d'élèves ont d'ailleurs préféré choisir
les autres menus ce avec de la viande ou
du poisson alors êtes vous favorable
menus végétariens dans les cantines
scolaires
êtes vous favorable à l'or gilles verdez
oui c'est formidable ce mairie fait
bouger les lignes et c'est un choix il
peut dire je n'en veux pas je mange de
la viande mais si on ne dit rien ce sont
des menus végétariens avec des légumes
avec plein de choses c'est équilibré
c'est bien il est précurseur
bien sûr il a fait
rétropédaler
départ il a dit ça veut dire et à rien
et bien sûr tous les global parce que
les parents étaient tous contre binôme
et vous inquiétez pas
directement ou du poisson si vous le
c'est ça le vrai débat c'est au départ
est arrangeant au départ et celle des
hôtes et spectateurs s'étaient repas
végétarien pour tout le monde
tweet il apparut louis dit maintenant la
norme ses repas végétariens et ensuite
il y aura des options pour ceux qui
veulent du poisson ou du carton avons ce
débat européen avec viande et poulet et
options végéta voilà exactement il dit
nous contraint les végétaliseurs les
cours d'école et de développer les
places piétonnes devant nos écoles mois
après il avait aimé au départ c'était je
vous dis la question c'est pas on peut
prendre de la viande du poisson parce
que ce qui va arriver c'est que
végétarien bal aura pas tu crois pas à
la demande esta de la viande du poisson
donc est ce que vous êtes pour ou contre
les menus végétariens dans les cantines
scolaires oui moi je trouve c'est une
bonne idée on peut pas se plaindre tout
le temps du fait que les français
mangent trop de viande et notamment de
vendre rouge et les habitués dès leur
plus jeune âge à manger de la viande
tous les jours à tous les repas donc
franchement c'est une bonne idée et ça
montre qu'on peut manger de manière
équilibrée sans manger de la viande mais
voilà on peut pas se plaindre de ça et
mathieu merci
qui va avoir la date
si c'est au choix c'est formidable parce
que je reçoive mais je rejoins guillaume
effectivement sur le fait que habitués
tout doucement les enfants à manger
moins de viande rouge moins de viande
tout court les abattoirs et tout ça
c'est une très bonne idée d'avoir le
choix si en revanche c'est pas le choix
c'est une honte totale évidemment en
posture à des carences tous hâte une
connerie sans nom mais si le choix c'est
formidable c'est pour ça attention c'est
quoi le
alors bus être au départ j'étais fan
choix un choix énorme connerie là bien
comment ce mois d'avril comme a dit
géraldine allemand rétropédalage ses 94
% des enfants et des parents d'élèves
ont demandé les autres menus c'est à
dire le menu avec viande ou le menu avec
aux poissons
s'écoute on le voit de loin je te voit
mourir
[Rires]
lorsqu'il dit moi j'en peux plus du
maire de grenoble franchement à
schaerbeek est une galère chaque fois
kenora c'est le maire de grenoble perd
il faut qu'il arrête je suis pressé que
son mandat se termine et que les gens
votent pas pour lui mais à présent dix
nouveaux américains n'ont ils devaient
sur un dépliant n'est pas plus efficace
et moi j'entre moi j'en peux plus lui à
chaque fois qu'elle est une galère c'est
lui après comme à dix matches et si on
laisse le poisson commence à tourner
je veux pas qu'on impose du végétarien
si les gens veulent manger de la barbe à
laisser les gens manger de la viande si
les gens vont être végétarien laisser
des gens et végétales moi ça me saoule
ce truc là on se bat et puis toi
l'hôpital dit pourrait te donne quoi
c'est varié scénario
alors nino non je les ai réfléchi à fait
d'accord avec moi je serais fait
d'accord avec mathieu et en plus on
oublie qu'il ya des gens des enfants qui
ne mangent pas forcément de viande tous
les jours chez eux et à ses chiens et
des enfants d'ouvriers dans un genre
assez cher la viande et il ya des gens
qui en mangent pas tous les jours et
c'est l'occasion à la cantine d'en
manger quasiment tous les jours donc au
contraire faut absolument pas passer par
la case star pas mal pour une fois qu'il
ya vraiment une mesure qu'il faut
prendre par rapport à l'avion par
rapport à la pollution que ça engendre
15% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre voir loin de la creuse et c'est à
cause de cette à cause de l'élevage pour
le coup il faut manger moins de viande
on le sait ces mesures mais plutôt quand
merdé le psg avec les jets effectivement
la viande c'est un vrai gros problème
que sur et tout le monde peut se
mobiliser et là franchement alors j'aime
pas le merde non plus mais c'est pas con
proposer des repas mais là parfois tu
dis non insulino est-ce que c'est
obligatoire mais m'a dit la raison ni
non pas d'écologie punitive il faut
qu'on apprenne il faut qu'on nous
explique et parfois les mots misons que
un bon repas etc à la cantine et on va
leur dire vous allez manger que du tofu
et de l'est du quinoa ben non
un steak haché avec la purée un truc
bien quoi alors du coup bien sûr des
films vous êtes avait alors moi je
trouve que c'est une avancée qui les
précurseurs que clairement dans dix ans
ce sera partout comme ça tu parles de
végétarisme punitif actuellement les
végétariens c'est pas que du quinoa et
du boulgour
alors moi je suis devenue végétarienne à
l'âge de quatre ans donc non à l'achat
sera c'est ça non c'est pas vrai donc je
peux prouver à l'âge de 80 ans donc
comment sa série j ai donc je peux trop
je peux prouver que c'est réussi et
qu'on n'a pas de carences et qui a aucun
souci non mais c'est pas ça l'âge de 4
ans qui a pris la décision mais moi
en allant voter quatre ans cyril
opposant la troupe non mais ils sont
tout à fait d'un enfant non mais moi
j'ai décidé envers et contre tous comme
aussi un choix et vos parents ils
continuent à manger de la viande et vous
leur disais non tu assez fou en force et
ils ont tout essayé ça n'a pas
fonctionné et donc depuis quatre ans
n'ai jamais mangé le même temps les
quatre ans et même un même
[Rires]
alors oui en fait c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre par exemple quand vous êtes
petit vous tombez on vous dit on vous
donne un gâteau comme ça ça vous vous
êtes mieux alors comme ça quand vous
êtes plus grand vous avez des chagrins
d'amour vous manger des gâteaux on vous
dit aussi quand vous êtes petit vous
allez manger de la viande pour devenir
fort du cook pour vous étant adulte
c'est un dit enfin l'on pense à bien
manger lire plein de gens qui demandent
delphine n'a j'aimerais vraiment manger
et manger un morceau de viande depuis 26
ans non puis 26 n'ont jamais jamais pas
un morceau de viande mais rien mais non
on
le fait sur des idées reçoit son nom
enfin un peu de poisson mer eh bien oui
les gens mangent pas dur en plein air
mais pas les deux plaisirs en mai
dernier c'est comme ça dans la
c'est les jeunes à aller chercher au
centre aéré
vous avez bien vu ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en terme de climat c'est
vraiment alarmant si aujourd'hui le
monde entier était végétarien on aurait
plus de problème de kno vraiment moi moi
alors tu l'as vu à quatre ans
bah oui oui mais pour les animaux mais
en l'occurrence ses traits à la barre
vibre ouvert c'est très bon thompson
donc je répète et les motoristes vivre
pardon si tout le monde était déjà
terminée celle à finir où tout le monde
était végétarien il n'y aurait plus de
problèmes de climat et si tout le monde
était juste à rien tout le monde ne
mangerai à sa fin comment fait que la
chine est pour déboucher comme une façon
bien des récents troubles aimons les
bifurque sur quelque chose m'a bien des
domaines précis on a on a dû être pas
aujourd'hui qui fait du steak mais
j'étais pas très belle part de marché de
femmes doivent pas se renier avec le
steak de cheval moi j'ai région et
manger un cheeseburger king tout fait
pas ok et je voulais aussi rajoute prime
aujourd'hui les enfants ne connaissent
pas la moitié des fruits et des légumes
enfin ne témoin moi mon fils y y et
amine hier mon fils est vraiment je lui
montre une orange ouais savait pas il
serait pas une bonne âme non mais il
paraît que c'est une banane
plus fonction crédit ou pas mais ça
devient la folie récemment plusieurs
années des raisons qui m'a dit donne moi
des figues oui et en termes nutritifs il
vaut mieux une ratatouille et du
boulgour avec du match avec plein de
choses on va découvrir des saveurs
plutôt que du hachis parmentier où il y
aura que du glucides alors on
attend justement est-ce que vous amicaux
à mykonos des objets d'art attaque
sans
dire un mot à dancing oui alors il cale
bouzid ami et je soutiens ce mr bravo
bravo parce que l'école et on verrait
compte alors il doit nous écouter les
dans sa chambre actuellement alors oui
non monsieur vous serez précurseur
chères de chine aucune aucune dans aucun
domaine aucune de solution n'est dans
les extrêmes exercées nord sais pas il
faut pas manger que de la viande nous
manger que végétarien adressée à
monsieur de viande un peu de légumes et
c'est toujours voilà c'est toujours en
faisant un petit peu de quelque chose
qu'on éduque les enfants et que même
dans la vie que même sur certains choix
politiques et tous qu'on avance bien en
général c'est pas dans les extrêmes qui
est des solutions il faut pas être que
ça ou que ça marche cela s'est passé à
l'aep entendu ce que même si un problème
d'environnement si les gens deviennent
végétarien c'est au kenya problèmes de
famine c'est des gens deviennent
végétariens ont réparti les ressources
stables bien non pas de bien des fonds
si l' on n'a même plus le voilà elle t'a
bien des fois là j'ai pris une
inattendue mais terme entre c'est vrai
gilles tu es d'accord avec delphine je
suis assez d'accord finalement je la
trouve convaincante moi je suis pas
végétarien mais encore une fois ce maire
c'est bien ce qui fait rappelons que la
loi maintenant c'est une fois par
semaine des menus végétariens parce
qu'on pensait que mais oui ils vont être
d'accord oui
[Applaudissements]
daniel magna n'était pas d'accord ah non
pas du tout tu mens je trouve étrange
beaucoup d'ordures non j'en mange plus
depuis très longtemps mais moi c'est
parce que j'aime pas c'est pas du tout
d'accord je mange du poisson bien sûr et
je trouve ça mais dangereux et je trouve
même je mange des pâtes thonidés captain
igloo
moi je mange des bateliers captain igloo
mais cacher captain igloo
je trouve dangereux ce que tu dis parce
qu'un pas que tu laisse à entendre qu'
on a évidemment tu es magnifique on a
envie de le faire comme toi tu sais des
asperges toute la journée
simplement non mais c'est vrai que c'est
éthiciens ici moi je pense quand même
que non non on en a des techniciens ici
pourquoi
je voudrais d'avoir un bloc très
intéressante par rapport révélé les
taureaux qui ont beaucoup beaucoup de
muscles on dit on mange de la viande ont
fait du muscle c'est entièrement faux
les ruraux mange que des herbes sérieux
et ils ont l'air et musculature et que
c'était donc ça il est reçu au total
j'ai vu doc gynéco qu'une que de l'herbe
y ait un côté série li hao tong
protéines dans les dents dans les
légumes en fait que dans
les taureaux ne mange que tu
as quand même les grands rires
merci je sais pour finir les steaks vers
le haut par non ça pollue encore plus
les sportifs série vous savez que les
plus grands sportifs sont végétariennes
et beaucoup plus madame et messieurs
tenir
que je vienne man siki nadal il est bien
sûr je les ai vus l'adrar fois vous
mangez une côte de boeuf
maintenant ils papier mais djoko djoko
ils mangeraient plus t'es moche quand
même chanson fourchette
tout